what
you put this cookies
[Music]
um
we're sorry
[Music]
foreign
thank you
it begins on a dark night
[Music]
look at this
you're not gonna find another girl like
her in a million years
[Music]
done I've never
hey there my apologies to you watching
on the mug club and Rumble this is the
second uh cold open because we don't
know what was going on with YouTube
doesn't surprise me uh the stream
wouldn't work we had to kind of kind of
Jerry rig it we had some workarounds but
look this is uh important for the folks
out there you know I've told you in the
past this is a PG-13 show uh this is not
a trigger warning that's a silly silly
term for silly people this is however an
age appropriate warning we are going to
be discussing and laying out the
historical case and what is going on now
with the UN not only their involvement
with underage sex trafficking in an
irrefutable way all the references are
available but now they're um they're
actual encouraging of uh sex with minors
and because it's important for you as a
parent it's important for you as an
American as a taxpayer it's important
for you as an adult to have this
information so that you can protect the
most vulnerable innocent Among Us
children I also know that this is not uh
appropriate for those children they
should be protected from this
information you know it so that they
don't have to so if you have children I
highly recommend they don't watch this
program today there will be some serious
subject matter along with very unserious
subject matter and look we've been
suspended on YouTube for simply
including the words pedophilia or map in
the title so there's a good chance that
this gets removed from YouTube before
the stream is even done anything you
guys can do to share post let other
people know uh where they can watch this
ideally on Rumble today because we're
willing to uh you know what uh roll the
dice here we're willing to let the cards
fall where they may it's an important
subject it's not a conspiracy theory it
is something that has been unilaterally
agreed upon across Nations but no one
talks about it so appreciate the support
hold on to your butts Let's uh Mark
rippeto reads real German folk stories
to kids that's fun
[Music]
hi kids they wanted me to read you a
story today so I've picked one out of uh
Dr Heinrich Hoffman's book pretty
stories and funny pictures
so let's read one today this one looks
this one looks nice the story of the
inky boys
as he had often done before the woolly
headed Blackmore
one nice fine summer's day went out to
see the shops and walk about then Edward
a little noisy wag ran out and laughed
and waved his flag and William came in
jacket trim and brought his wooden hoop
with him and Arthur too snatched up his
toys and joined the other naughty boys
and kept on singing only think
oh Blackie you're as black as ink
you guys want to hear the rest of this
[Music]
okay
negripa lived close by so tall he almost
touched the sky and had a mighty ink
stand too in which a giant goose feather
grew he called out in an angry tone boys
leave the Blackmore alone for if he
tries with all these might he cannot
change from black to white he sees his
Arthur sees his Ned takes William by his
little head
and they may scream and kick and call
into the ink he dips them all into the
ink stand one two three to their black
as black can be because they set up such
a Roar and teased the harmless Blackmore
let this be a lesson to you
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
today is the day where the T does
nothing I I still have that red tide
of course really it's the red tide
there's no way to get rid of it I feel
better it's that phase where everything
is you know kind of working its way out
so I I'll be hitting the cough button a
lot so you'll probably be seeing me
talking and going
today quite a bit uh and Casey gagging
yes glad to be with you a lot to get to
today if you watch the cold open look I
appreciate you sharing posting because
this is the beauty of uh of my club is
being able to discuss these issues and
and not caring we don't want to be
removed from YouTube but we will allow
ourselves to be punished uh at the cost
of truth if that phrase makes any sense
so we'll be talking today about teachers
playing the licking game with your kids
that's a real thing I'll be talking
about the Fox News Dominion settlement
and I think people are conflating the
issue as far as election interference
and what's happening with Fox they
screwed up on some specifics that we
warned against when it happened however
there are some Ripple effects here that
could negatively affect other news
outlets and really the meat of what
we'll be discussing today is
um the U.N they just had a committee
it's tough because the U.N has sort of
these you know contractors but let's
just use the term you and the umbrella
term uh they now are approving they've
proposed that's that sex with minors
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
there for you and what measures also
another question I would have what
measures do you think should be taken to
protect our children
from sexual predators I think that's one
of the most important issues we didn't
think that we would be facing it but
here we are it is a live show Monday
through Friday at 10 A.M Eastern just so
you know whatever there are
complications and you don't see us on
YouTube Just tune in 10 a.m head on over
to rumble Friday of course uh mug Club
this is the last week of free mug Club
lottery.com mug club and uh then of
course you can join up and you'll
continue to get access to all the things
that you are missing all right we're
going to move on Gerald a number two CEO
how are you I am doing well how are you
man it's uh it's tough for me to breathe
a little bit because I have the drip
yeah you guys know what I'm it's like
you it almost feels like a submarine
door when you try and talk and you keep
having a story yeah you know what I mean
it's like closes the valve like Celine
Dion when she hits the high note where
she's like
it's nasally yeah
that makes sense yeah I'm with you
you're always doing you feel better and
then no he's doing well what do I have
to complain about
I mean I'm looking at you I'm the CEO
and uh Nick depalo is going to be here
in third year tomorrow you guys
obviously loved him he's as tough so far
and rough as they come and his show is
available at 5 PM uh Eastern here on mug
Club but today in third chair we brought
back his theme music you know him you
love him I uh come from his uh his I
came from his weiner it is pops Crowder
I did
how does that feel
I love it yeah thank you you ever look
at me and think
you're in because women all the time
limit all the time all right okay what
were you about to say about I was going
to go in a direction that clearly isn't
productive
your comments about the red tide have
single-handedly destroyed tourism on the
Gulf Coast oh no Sarasota is wonderful
visiting it yeah yeah yeah but I do have
the right time yeah except when there's
dead fish on every Beach there's a lot
of dead puffer fish all right so uh
let's step on it hit the like button I
guess so
this is one of our first stories and at
first when I read the headline I thought
okay come on now this is you're being a
little sensationalist and then I watched
it right and I I couldn't make sense of
it I don't know if my brain just like
doesn't have a chip for it
which it probably doesn't matter fact I
know it doesn't so teachers at Desert
Hills Middle School they hosted a
fundraiser which went viral for playing
uh what is referred to as the licking
game with their students
thank you
the kids are going this isn't right
[Music]
this is a good idea
The Biggest Loser in all this by the way
uh social distancing
I guess Cove is not I guess we're not
doing the covet thing anymore well they
got to repurpose those dividers those
teachers are so brave you know they just
they went right there at the front lines
right now looking whatever that is off
of the sneeze yeah the sneeze shield
from Golden Corral that white substance
yeah it wasn't a screen it was
plexiglass it was plexiglass yeah it was
the last guy there was the school
security officer yeah who's watching
who's protecting the kids no he was into
it he's like yeah yeah look the
lifestyle yeah do it like that do it
like that I said he he waited did you
see him pause it wasn't even licking
fast to kind of win the game he waited
until the other person was licking to
lick at the same time I don't and this
could just be a game but again it's like
you know shouldn't you just be aware of
the fact that so many people are
concerned with you being pedophiles that
you say is there a game we could do
where we're not pantomiming licking each
other is it a possibility
maybe two games Red Rover British
Bulldog no anyone dodgeball okay we're
gonna go what's a licking game all right
all right I think that guy would sound
like ground groundskeeper Willie yes I
saw them licking the glass
[Music]
thank you
all right guys rules are super simple
all we're going to do is lick it from
both sides like just lick it yeah
just lick it
that's kind of up
[Music]
I mean all right it's a trend well at
least it's the New Meme yeah it's a new
planking well no we had adults they did
it with uh you know 12 year olds around
well it doesn't help that I force the
adults to do it and whoever uh lost well
actually whoever won would be crucified
oh what yeah we do we do licking and we
mix it with a little bit of Spartacus oh
geez
very biblical of you
guys didn't see Spartacus they make them
fight to the death Tony Curtis and uh
and Douglas and then whoever wins gets
crucified it's a fantastic scene because
I would just love because they're trying
to mercifully kill their friend it's a
terrific movie you say Brutus I said I'd
rather lose that's the old one Spartacus
there is only one what do you think what
are you thinking about you're thinking
about the Cory Booker's part that's not
a real movie it's just things he says
words sometimes that's him in the
hearing okay yeah yeah this is the
closest I get to the I am Spartacus
moment uh you mean never getting close
to an I'm Spartacus
that's pre-time Cruz when other Leading
Men could be five five yes exactly good
yes he was muscled like a Greek god at
all five feet five inches of them five
foot nothing 100 and nothing are you him
are you he shut up Spartacus hey
are you Z get my pronouns so uh yeah you
know we're buying time until we have to
get to the U.N pedophile thing because
it's uncomfortable but it's something
that we have to do so before that let's
have a little pick-me-up uh in crime
news uh NYPD Chief uh I guess chief of
Crime Control I don't know what the
terms mean uh let's just say his name is
Michael Le Petri a reported that 327
people now here's the thing you want to
talk about a culture of crime I've said
this their goal is to create
well their goal is to turn law-abiding
citizens into criminals right which you
easily do like in the state of
Washington if you're going to take
children away from their parents if they
don't you know conduct a sex change
operation right you will turn those
parents into criminals because they're
going to protect their children by any
means necessary so in New York they
really are further along the trail in
turning law-abiding citizens into
criminals and turning criminals into
voters you create a culture of
criminality because uh for this is
Picture Perfect proof that people who
disobey laws won't obey new laws no
matter how many you create because
there's a percentage of the population
who have decided that they are going to
be criminals for the rest of their lives
this is why when people say the War on
Drugs has failed and it has but the idea
that legalizing all drugs will end it no
no drug cartels are not drug cartels
they're criminals who happen to make
money off of drugs one point they made
money off of Wheat and they made money
off of cocaine depending who you're
dealing with now they've made money to
make money off of fentanyl you legalize
that they're going to make money off of
underage sex trafficking like there's
some kind of a U.N official the point is
they've decided that they want to live a
life of crime tax-free
regardless of the mechanism that is used
that's shown very clearly here in New
York with 327 people
all references are 327 people New York
is a big city I don't know if you know
that's a lot of 327. there's not a lot
of people no no in New York there's a
lot that's not that's not a lot 327
people committed one-third of all the
shoplifting
327 people that account for 30 percent
of all the arrests of all the arrests
327 people have
thirty percent of our 22 000.
get off the phone
[Laughter]
lifters have you ever heard of the
concept of other people like me needing
to use the phone so here's the odd thing
the New York Post
reported on this in January and the New
York Times covered it only last weekend
so you know
[Music]
rag said that he's going to be coming
down hard on these recidivists which is
progress by can he's going to be
convincing the state legislature to pass
a firm 16 strikes law
that's 16th time hey don't make me count
to 24.
fool me 16 times fool me 16 times I'm a
corrupt Soros funded D.A that's I
believe the colloquialism idiom whatever
that brings us to this week's
installment of Empire State of crime
dreams
[Music]
[Applause]
if it was only a true song that would be
yes it's a good song I like the beat
yeah well he does he does rap about how
I used to sell uh used to sell drugs
down in bedside now he's up in Tribeca
right next to DeNiro oh well that's good
for that man's in a co-op with Robert De
Niro I don't know any of these things
that you said you're playing your music
too loud
I'm not I
yes you are issue you're playing your
music very much too loud but
we're responsible for over 7 000 arrests
that's also 7 000 releases that's a big
threat you're missing that you're
missing the happy ending that's right
they're really not for the ladies they
raped but yes go ahead they literally
they it's 20 times roughly on average
per I mean person is plus or minus do
you get like a freaking flyer thing or
something like a punch card that you
give to the detective every time you get
arrested for shoplifting and they just
let you go like what the hell would you
take those seven thousand out that's a
pretty good stat for a city that size
yeah you're not doing too bad yeah
exactly take them out take out the trash
hey speaking of which nothing at my
sleep CNN right now speaking of
criminals who should be in jail they're
talking about Alec Baldwin's film rust
to resume production tomorrow bring it
up really quickly heard and we know that
Dave Halls the assistant director who
you know Alec Baldwin maintains handed
him the gun yeah they retitled it to
murder Shmurder so Monday night in the
uh the Bronx this is again what we're
talking about New York just again a
microcosm of what they want to bring to
your country there was a drive-by
shooting that happened right in front of
Carl Hasty's office who is the speaker
of the State uh assembly a drive-by
shooting in the Bronx left one person
hospitalized this morning that's right
the shooting took place right outside
the office of State Assembly speaker
Carl Hasty he has been an advocate for
what some consider the state's lenient
criminal justice reforms that's right
diversity higher nice tits as we talk
about this did you see his eyes look at
this come on this guy got caught come on
scientific evidence but they're both
stunning he doesn't mean the lights are
the lights dark today or is it just me
it's just you could just be me okay a
little dark I was born in the dark nice
tits
here's the thing this is uh this is
Hasty's this is the second shooting in
front of his local office in New York
one of the leading proponents of
Criminal Justice reforms in New York
state that critics have damned as too
lenient back in October the president of
the detective's endowment Association
appeared on Good Day New York and said
that there was another shooting outside
Hasty's office earlier in 2022. and that
office was not cooperated Cooperative
with the detectives investigating that
crime wow that guy sounds exactly like
how I would have thought he sounded in a
silly impression
how many times is that I don't know but
I said once too many it's bad
change your voice if you look that way
yeah
professent so here's the thing
contrast is what matters here right
another crime that deserves attention in
New York uh Kalyn Gillis was a 20 year
old woman she was shot and killed
pulling into a driveway in Upstate New
York okay uh Kevin Monahan 65 has been
charged and arrested arrested and
charged sorry to be a sequence with
second-degree murder now this shooting
occurred Saturday okay there was uh no
mention of race I wonder why we've
barely been hearing about it uh and
here's the thing let's contrast that
with of course the Kansas City shooting
that you know about right this comes
from CNN white homeowners accused of
shooting black teen who went into the
wrong house in Kansas City will face two
felony charges officials announced right
there was another one that was seen in
New York heldine it was it was all
racially motivated we searched this
morning we did a whole segment on this
yesterday we searched CNN's on-air
mentions of the shooter Kevin Monahan
and we compared it with Andrew Lester
from Monday to today CNN mentioned
Monahan 20 times 23 times and Lester 47
times over twice as many times and in
the first case this girl was killed was
killed the second case they just made it
about race and the guy was released from
the hospital the next day now obviously
and the first one by the way it seems
like the cops right away said yeah
that's murderer no it's murder because
murder you can't do it whereas in the
second case the cops said oh he was he
was just grabbing your door jam and this
is self-defense so again one should be
if we're going to discuss Common Ground
okay let's all find Common Ground here
and the other is we need to wait for
some information this just tells you
that the media is not doing the job
they're supposed to their job is to
provide you with information so that
ultimately not just to provide you with
information why why does the news exist
it is supposed to improve your life it
is supposed to give you information that
you can apply
[Music]
was white
yeah yeah talk about making it all it
was the white white you can search
stories and never find a description of
a perp ever the lead word was white man
shoots black right unbelievable and what
happened in New York they don't even
cover it and uh New York's not coming
back just so you know they'll try and
say oh crime has gone down a little bit
well yeah that's because of the you know
the opposite rebound effect it went up
so high that there's really nowhere else
to go it is a horrible hellscape and if
you live there you're a silly person
this has been Empire State of crime
[Music]
[Applause]
I just want to see that
they're pansies to resume production
tomorrow didn't normally they they
resume shooting yeah but not in this
class
they were like they're gonna
they're going to produce things they're
going to turn the little button on the
camera yes
yeah the director's going to say all
right let's shoot the oh let's film this
these people fear no account and by the
way it could be an accident that took
place because Alec Baldwin was
incredibly ignorant though he was
certainly violating the guidelines of
firearm safety but I'm willing to
understand the idea that it was an
accident the problem is there's such a
lack of self-awareness that he's still
going out trying to take away your guns
but now we're gonna have to deal with
that CGI gun blast on every yeah exactly
it's just like now every animal is CGI
does this bother you comment below what
was it I was just watching I watched
cocaine bear I don't recommend it but
same thing that film that same thing
with Idris Elba and the Lions what was
it called I don't know but you compare
that with The Ghost and the Darkness you
compare that with the edge where they
use a real bear where they use real
lines and then sometimes these animals
like it's no longer we are at a point
where film is definitively becoming
worse yes when when when the lion paw
goes through the car and goes
feels its head like
what am I watching Scooby-Doo
I blame Michael Bay I blame PETA
yeah and we have a whole segment on them
tomorrow both are correct biggest
euthanizer of uh of animals maybe the
ones that are supposed to save animals
yeah in Virginia yeah they have a they
have a euthanization rate that's give or
take eight times the rate of other
shelters oh geez yeah yeah good old
Peter so all right let's move on here to
talk about uh Fox News oh Lord there are
some issues here look just to be clear
and if we're on YouTube by the way
thank you
[Music]
people knew that they had been misled
people knew that they had been
manipulated you had some grifters come
in or you had people in some cases
grifters yet and some people who
knowingly spread misinformation to try
and capitalize on it and in some cases
you had people who just didn't know any
better they didn't know any better so
they were fooled by the charlatans so we
need to separate the fact that yes
[Music]
diligence and then Fox News decided to
disseminate that information and and
where they screwed up is the records
show that Fox News knew that it wasn't
legitimate so first off if you haven't
been following this uh the network now
they just had to settle with Dominion
here's a clip so you don't have to take
my route for it as part of the
settlement Fox agreed to pay Dominion
787.5 million dollars just less than
half of the 1.6 billion they were suing
for fox has admitted to telling lies
about Dominion that caused enormous
damage to my company our employees and
the customers that we serve
okay so and just because this is always
a third rail today we're talking about
this and the UN please do hit the like
button or share on YouTube uh right now
and head on over to rumble if you can
just tell them to hit the button there
on the toolman go to rumble what are you
doing go to rumble uh but do help share
it helps with the algorithms because you
won't be able to find it okay here's the
problem that happened with Fox News and
we'll contrast it with how we covered
election interference which of course is
one of the biggest issues of our time
just want to make sure that people so
you're selling out no I'm saying that
Fox News screwed up here's how there are
many people at Fox News who did not
believe the claims that they were making
and that includes Murdoch that included
allegedly Sean Hannity yeah perhaps
Laura Ingram right these were people who
said you know what we shouldn't be
covering this this isn't accurate which
we said about Dominion just to be clear
but Mike Liddell seems like a nice guy
who loves his country he was wrong yeah
when the information first came out we
said he's actually wrong in the way he's
trying to track uh some of these votes
the way the software this actually
doesn't make any sense and so we decided
to focus exclusively on things that we
could proof doesn't mean that there
couldn't be issues with Dominion voting
of course but there is no way to prove
it and I also understand that that's a
problem it's almost impossible to prove
but you can't go out on a News Network
and knowingly espouse views that you
understand at that point to be false
that was foreign
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
for people in these countries to protect
themselves against sexual exploitation
and child prostitution 2017.
former senior U.N official Andrew McLeod
just to be clear heeda dossier that
estimated and I'll explain this
estimated over 60 000 sexual assaults
over a 10-year period wow he also
estimated that the U.N employed up to 3
300 pedophiles now according to him
there are tens of thousands of Aid
workers around the world with pedophile
Tendencies but if you were a UNICEF
t-shirt nobody will ask you what you're
up to and he did this estimate because
he talked about how many pedophiles
actually get caught versus how many sex
crimes go underreported and then he
extrapolated that so yes there has to be
an estimate but the reason it has to be
an estimate is because nothing is ever
done
about this we so the the reason
nothing's ever done about this is the
way that the UN sets this up right the
very people that are supposed to go and
protect yes and be responsible for
making sure that peace is kept in these
places there's no accountability with
the UN because they're soldiers or
people from other countries and so all
they literally do is send them home
right the punishment for these crimes
they say well the home country has to
take care of that we can't do it in Home
Country almost never does a and this is
it's just like public schools throwing
more money at it doesn't help we'll get
to the money your taxpayer dollars are
funding
funding the support of child
prostitution just to be clear but we're
not involved much in the peacekeeping
missions of the U.N I know Canada throws
it in a big way where's the blue helmet
goes in and right yeah because they they
claim that their Peacekeeper unloaded
guns you know who does more peacekeeping
the United States military yeah yeah but
I don't know if we're involved in that
much we give a lot of money to the U.S
it's all fungible which we'll get to and
we forgive their parking tickets yes yes
exactly
exactly on the east side I used to spend
some time there was actually put for you
there was a decent Pub but I saw a lot
of U.N officials with um you know kids
dressed up like Corey Haim which I
thought was weird that is weird yeah so
these people now advising
internationally hey
needs to be acceptable these people have
been unsurprisingly they have been
involved or certainly no involved
directly involved with child
prostitution and of course the New York
Times ran cover for them by the way the
New York Times if you look at where they
are in New York not too far from the UN
District not too far from where these
ambassadors would live they all go to
the same parties I've been to a lot of
these parties when I worked at Fox News
they all hang out with each other and
this is not some kind of crazy
conspiracy or cabal it's about people
who never heard of the term of
networking what do you think happens
when you're networking with horrible
people
you got Jeffrey Epstein yep okay so the
New York Times tried to run interference
and discredit the dossier writing an
article called lies damn lies and one
very misleading statistic now whether
that 60 000 number is completely
accurate or not
there is a laundry list there is a long
history of the UN having a huge problem
with this so I cannot tell you the 60
000 number is right I would actually
guess it's probably higher just to be
clear but I cannot prove that just like
we talked about with Fox News and
Dominion everything else that I've told
you I can prove and I have more that I
can prove let me get you just had the
empirical you just had the warnings that
came from ambassadors now let me give
you some case studies uh in Haiti U.N
peacekeepers were accused and again I
did this in the cold open if you have
children they should not be here some
we're not going to be showing you
anything that's like rape on camera but
there are some disturbing videos
one peacekeepers in Haiti were accused
and then there was proof but first
accused of a multitude of sexual crimes
any Haitian can tell you about U.N
Peacekeeper sections women and children
with almost no consequences peacekeepers
were abusing women and girls and traded
food or or cash for for sexual favors
United Nations peacekeepers there to
help are accused of adding to the harm
a study claims they fathered hundreds of
babies then abandoned the young mothers
some only children themselves
we had plenty of stories of peacekeepers
engaging with with young young girls and
young women under the age of 18 which
um is of course as we all know statutory
rape yeah I mean it's just rape well but
but hold on not according to what the
U.N is now saying exactly changing the
rules on the exactly you know it's not
ready for goal post if it's like asking
murderers to vote on the laws of murder
the U.N should have no say in the
normalizing of pedophilia they because
they've committed these crimes against
humanity that term is thrown around
these are crimes against humanity let me
give you some more numbers here that are
irrefutable you can go and check these
for yourselves at least 134 Sri Lankan
peacekeepers
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
the international body was aware of
shortcomings in the system that is not a
mundane detail Michael that's not enough
of response when you combine that with
the fact that you're advocating for
pedophilia across the globe makes me
think you kind of like the pedophilia
makes me think you kind of like the
underage sex trafficking
no justice for the victims as far as I
know no arrests no one went to jail but
114 peacekeepers were sent home
and the 21 year old rape victim in this
case was not a minor but still a gang
rape victim so it's relevant
ah as far as the UN goes they came here
to protect us but all they've brought is
uh destruction now the U.N has no moral
foundation and you go into these
countries that are voodoo Nations like a
lot like Haiti you have to go in there
with some kind of moral standing you
can't send a hodgepodge of folks from
different countries there's got to be a
basis of of basic human conduct Empower
so look the easy solution to this is
Empower whoever is in charge of the
troops in that country you treat them
just like they should be treated your
soldiers you walk into that room and
there's a gun Lang
oh
M that's the punishment nothing will
which by the way also tells you that
they live in shitholes yes it's like
what what is My Punishment we have to go
back to your house oh no
can I have my smartphone please there's
[Music]
thank you
just give money to these countries by
the way you're trying to help these
countries that are corrupt and violent
and they commit rape and massive numbers
and you say well let's contract to those
to those folks no no that's why you you
either don't go in and you are a
non-interventionist and you let them
descend back into the third world or
descend deeper into the third world or
you go in like missionaries where you
kill all of their corrupt leaders and
you convert them to Christianity you
don't say hey all cultures are equal and
let's come in and let something oh you
raped a couple of kids but we understand
that that's how you believe you get rid
of age no no it's bang bang bang bang
bang bang you don't get a dime until uh
you know you come back and you have
reverend in your name okay we'll see you
later yeah exactly by the way we wore
these shirts for a reason yes yes we are
very much pro-gun I guarantee every one
of these guys that was raped in this 100
I couldn't believe it a hundred and
something people involved in this ring
that's not a small secret it's not a
small secret trafficking kids 150 people
and these come bind is what led to the
60 000 estimate which you know what okay
let's say it's half that all right well
then let's go through the money and the
funding that we provide to the U.N let
me give you another case study
Africa I mean the continent because
there's so many different countries
there but the Central African Republic
uh has been an absolute hotbed uh for
abuse here's a clip in the same month as
a secretary General's visit to the
Central African Republic the UN received
a report of a new rape case in bambari a
young woman was found half naked and
barely conscious right here the foot of
these stairs she says she was walking
home after a funeral and the last thing
she clearly remembers is being offered a
cup of tea by you and peacekeepers at
this checkpoint here just behind me her
family then wanted to know what had
happened to the mauritanian soldiers
[Music]
again it's not that systems sometimes
right there are errors it's that this
system has not worked the way that they
farm this out and their policies of
course with the UN it hasn't worked it's
led to sexual assault over the course of
decades you saw that document I showed
you from 1996 and they still keep doing
it the same way nothing changes these
peacekeepers have been coming from quote
unquote Rogue Nations for a very long
time but they don't change it annual
contract from the United Nations to
Burundi to provide peacekeepers sustains
this government's military Burundi which
is a rogue country that has been accused
of all kinds of Human Rights abuses
silly markers
to the Central African Republic as
peacekeepers and expects them to to
behave they end up raping and uh
sexually exploiting the local population
and the government of Burundi does
nothing it doesn't conduct
investigations it doesn't do its job and
we're going to continue on with the
problem with foreign aid because the
problem with foreign aid is this idea
that this is why I've said there's no
Common Ground well there's no purpose in
finding common ground where there is no
Common Ground are we going to act like
we share the same values as the Congo
are we going to act like we even share
the same values as the French government
then why would we link arms would you
link arms with a pedophile would you
link arms with someone who thinks it's
okay to have sex with a 12 year old no
that's what we're doing and we're doing
it to the tune of billions of dollars
this is why globalism is evil it's why
it has to fail because all it does is
Elevate when you are here's the thing
the United States is far from perfect
but
when the United States is the world's
only superpower and we take part in
elevating other nations guess what the
only value that we get is nothing the
value they get is potentially elevating
themselves close to the level of the
United States and a lot of these
countries are evil as a matter of policy
so they benefit from it and we always
serve to do here is Elevate and increase
the profile and the power of evil we
don't need to do it as Americans we
should keep doing it the American way
not the U.N way so I'm going to go on
here and talk about France and uh I
don't know if you know this open borders
they support a lot of underage a lot of
underage sex slaves trafficked across
the open borders but because we've been
doing this you know for this this month
uh the show is supposed to be an hour on
YouTube and on Rumble so you can still
watch for free it's the end of Fremont
club week we're going to continue this
segment uh but we're going to continue
this and the conclusion a lot more to
discuss regarding the UN but exclusively
on Rumble and mugler so you have an idea
as to what you'll be getting so YouTube
we love you we thank you we don't love
you
that's Instinct we're going to continue
with you but right now YouTube piss off
old man Rumble